Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özgüval. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmengespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten und dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich habe der Sekretärin meine Daten gegeben. Warum fragen Sie mich noch mal?
Das ist für uns sehr wichtig, um gleiche Namen mit anderen Patienten nicht zu verwechseln. Das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Ok, danke.
Um sehr wohl zu gehen.
Ok, na klar. Ich heiße Philipp Kea, Herr Doktor.
Philipp Kea. Können Sie bitte den Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ok, Herr Doktor. Mein Vornamen buchstabiert sich P wie Paula, H wie Heinrich, I wie Ida, L wie Ludwig, I wie Ida und am Ende Doppel P wie Paula.
Und mein Nachname ist K wie Kaufmann, E wie Emil, Y wie Emil und am Ende R wie Richard.
Bei dem Vornamen nur eine L.
Nur Doppel P.
Und Doppel P. Vielen Dank. Alles gut. Herr Kea, wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
59 Jahre alt. Alles gut. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 11.11.1965 geboren.
65 geboren. Das passt. Herr Kea, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, bitte beeilen Sie sich, Herr Doktor. Ich habe Angst. Ich habe Muschimärzen.
Ich bin 1,90 Meter. Entschuldigung, Sie haben die Gewichtskragen.
Alles gut.
Ich wiege 90 Kilogramm und ich bin 1,90 Meter groß. Entschuldigung. Alles gut.
Ich bin ein bisschen verriet wegen meiner Schmerzen.
Alles gut. Herr Kea, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wie gesagt habe ich Brustschmerzen, Herr Doktor. Obwohl Sie jetzt ein bisschen besser sind, habe ich seit zwei Stunden Brustschmerzen.
Seit zwei Stunden?
Ja, seit ungefähr zwei Stunden habe ich plötzlich so einen dumpfen, drückenden Schmerzen hier hinter dem Brustbein, Herr Doktor.
Seit zwei Stunden ein stehendes, brennendes Schmerz.
Nein, ein dumpfen und drückendes Schmerz.
Dumpfen und drückenden Schmerzen.
Vorher haben Sie einhebende Schmerzen?
Ja, vorher habe ich aber jetzt schwer und früher war es leichter als jetzige Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
In den letzten drei Monaten hatte ich schon ab und zu so ähnliche Beschwerden, aber wie gesagt waren sie viel leichter als jetzige.
Und ich würde gerne wissen ob die Schmerzen und Beschwerden einigermaßen aushalten können oder?
Was bitte?
Halten Sie aus die Schmerzen?
Das ist besser, aber es macht mir Angst.
Ich verstehe. Ich zähle die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Eigentlich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Eigentlich nicht.
Der Schmerz bleibt eher...
Vielleicht müssen Sie ihn in den Halsbereich...
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Der Schmerz bleibt eher in der Mitte der Brust, also direkt hinter dem Brustbein.
Vor der Brustbein oder hinter dem Brustbein? Wie beschreiben Sie das?
Hinter dem Brustbein.
Hinter dem Brustbein. Seit zwei Stunden.
Ungefähr.
Alles gut. Also nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie aktuell ein Medikament angenommen?
Herr Doktor, habe ich vielleicht Herzinfarkt oder Herzschlag?
Ja, kann ich nicht genau sagen. Ein paar Fragen stellen würde ich.
Wie beschreiben Sie, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Kein Schmerzen, wobei Sie sehr stark sind?
Am Anfang würde ich sagen, bei sechs von zehn. Im Moment ist es etwas besser.
Vielleicht drei bis vier. Aber ganz weg ist es eben nicht.
Alles gut. Und dagegen haben Sie kein Medikament eingefahren?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Direkt ins Krankenhaus.
Ich bin nicht gefahren.
Nein, Herr Doktor. Direkt ins Krankenhaus bin ich gefahren.
Ich verstehe Sie. Alles gut.
Herr Kehr, jetzt gibt es einen Notfallverdacht.
Ich muss diese Gespräche sofort beenden.
Ich werde Sie auf jeden Fall stationär aufnehmen und sofort einen EKG durchführen.
Dann ein paar Politische Laboren untersuchen.
Wenn alles gut geht, können wir weiterfahren. Alles gut?
Okay, Herr Doktor. Das hat mich ein bisschen beruhigt.
Ich werde Sie aufnehmen. Erst einmal ein großlämiger, lumiger Zugang legen und dann ein Elektrocardiogramm durchführen.
Okay, danke Herr Doktor.
Herr Kehr, wie geht es Ihnen?
Jetzt besser. Ich habe auch Schmerzen, aber ich fühle mich ein bisschen sicher.
Wie ist Ihre Brustschmerzen? Wie ist Ihre Brustschmerzen momentan?
Wie gesagt, Sie sind auch da, aber ich fühle mich sicher als Vorhaber.
Alles gut. Und können wir weiterführen?
Ja, bitte Herr Doktor.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass die Schmerzintensität am Anfang 6 und dann in Ruhe ist und jetzt 3 und 4.
Ja Herr Doktor.
Alles gut. Und Herr Winter, gibt es noch andere Beschwerden?
Vielleicht haben Sie noch andere Begleitsymptomen?
Ich weiss nicht, was die Begleitsymptomen sind, aber ich kann sagen...
Sie haben ein bisschen Katschweiß, Schweißausbruch.
Okay Herr Doktor. Ich hatte plötzlich schlechte Luft.
Also ein Gefühl von Atemnot. Mir war auch etwas übel währenddessen.
Aber ich musste nicht erbrechen Herr Doktor. Nur Übelkeit hatte ich.
Seit wann dauert diese Übelkeit?
Ich meine...
Heute Morgen?
Heute Morgen, seit 2 Stunden meine ich.
Aber keine Erbrechen? Und haben Sie Dyspno?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte ziemlich schlechte Luft. Vielleicht Atemnot.
Haben Sie Katschweiß?
Ja, und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich kalt geschwitzt habe und mich irgendwie total schlecht gefühlt habe Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe. Nur heute Morgen oder?
Ja, ich meine seit heute Morgen.
Alles gut. Haben Sie Vertigo?
Was ist Vertigo Herr Doktor?
Haben Sie Schwinden?
Nein, ich hatte nicht Schwinden. Nur Atemnot und Übelkeit und diese Katschweiß.
Müdigkeit, Fatigue?
Ja, ich fühle mich natürlich müde, aber nicht so erschöpft.
Alles gut. Sind Sie ein Hapartit und Durst?
Seit einer Stunde habe ich nichts gegessen, aber früher war es normal.
Haben Sie heute schon gefrühstückt oder etwas gegessen?
Heute Morgen habe ich gefrühstückt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist immer stabil Herr Doktor.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt. Vielleicht messen Sie es in körperlicher Untersuchung oder hier?
Ja natürlich. Aber am Anfang, ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten bemerkt? Zum Beispiel am Bein oder im Waden?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, gestern Nacht habe ich es bemerkt, aber ich habe keine Probleme mit Schlafen.
Haben Sie Angst?
Natürlich Herr Doktor, ich habe viel Angst.
Was für eine Angst?
Ich habe Angst vor Tod.
Ich verstehe. Alles gut.
Haben Sie noch eine andere chronische dauerhaftige Erkrankung? Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Vagakrankheit oder Bronchitis?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit etwa 15 Jahren Bluthochdruck.
15 Jahre Bluthochdruck.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es gut kontrolliert ist. Ich messe nicht regelmäßig, nur in der Praxis kontrolliert.
Nur in der Praxis. Alles gut.
Außerdem habe ich seit ungefähr zehn Jahren erhöhte Cholesterinwerte, Herr Doktor.
Und Cholesterinwerte?
Und ich habe schon länger eine chronische Hüste.
Chronische Hüste? Seit wann haben Sie eine chronische Hüste?
Seit Jahren, vielleicht 20 Jahren, weiß ich nicht.
Seit 20 Jahren?
Ja, mindestens 20 Jahre, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Alles gut. Und die Hüste mit Auswurf oder? Haben Sie Auswurf?
Meistens trocken, aber manchmal habe ich auch Spürtum. Aber meistens trocken.
Herr Kehr, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Herr Doktor, als ich zwölf Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Operation.
Was für eine Operation? Was meinen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht genau, aber während des Ressort Spielen hatte ich einen Unfall und eine Beinfraktur.
Wegen dieser Fraktur wurde bei mir eine Operation durchgeführt.
Operation durchgeführt.
Gab es eine Beinfraktur?
Ja, wie gesagt.
Beinfrussspieler. Rechte oder linke Fuß?
Rechte. Rechte Beine.
Das war komplikationlos oder?
Das war normal. Alle verlaufen komplikationlos.
Alle sind.
Herr Kehr, haben Sie eine Allergie gegen etwas?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Atmosallergie. Wenn ich Atmos esse, bekomme ich Atemnot und Schwellungen in den Mund. Deshalb passe ich da sehr auf.
Mundschwellungen. Und leicht Yukreas.
Hortausschlag. Nur Schwellungen. Mundschwellungen.
Und auch Atemnot, wie gesagt.
Und Atemnot.
Ernsthaft ist Atemnot für mich, wenn ich Atemnot esse.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe nicht Atemnot gehört.
Ich habe nur Mundschwellungen gehört. Nehmen Sie die regelmäßige Medikamentale?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich nehme Ramiplil 5 mg morgens und Simvastatin 40 mg abends. Einmal pro Tag. Und sonst eigentlich nichts regelmäßiges.
Ramiplil wie viel mg?
5 mg morgens.
40 mg abends.
Warum nehme ich Simvastatin abends, aber Ramiplil morgens?
Simvatate ist ein Gegenkollesterin Medikament.
Ja?
Ja, also Sie haben eine hohe Brutfertigkeit glaube ich. Und Ihrem Arzt hat Ihnen ein Simvastatin geschrieben.
Ok.
Und dann Herr Kair. Herr Kair, rauchen Sie?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich rauche ungefähr 3 Zigaretten am Tag.
3 Zigaretten? Seit wann?
Seit etwa 30 Jahren.
30 Jahren, täglich nur 3 Zigaretten.
3 Zigaretten.
Nicht so schlimm glaube ich. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Aber der Arzt hat mir gesagt, das ist auch schlimm, weil ich so lange geratet habe.
Ja natürlich. 30 Jahre.
Aber auch wenn die Zahlen wenig sind, soll man kurze Zeit rauchen. Aber nicht so rauchen.
Ja, ich verstehe natürlich, das ist nicht so gut. Aber als Allgemeingesellschaft täglich 30 Zigaretten ist sehr gut.
Normalerweise rauchen viele Jüngere täglich 1 Schachtel.
Ok, ich mache weiter zu rauchen Herr Doktor.
Nein, versuchen Sie es mal mit dem Rauchen auf sich.
Das war jetzt ja.
Ja, wir bitten für Sie eine Unterstützung.
Ja, weil mein Brustschmerzen ist weg, mache ich Witz Herr Doktor.
Ja, nach dem Gespräch können wir wieder sprechen über diesen Thema. Eine Unterstützung mit dem Rauchen aufzuholen.
Danke Herr Doktor.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich eher wenig Herr Doktor. Vielleicht ein bis zwei Mal pro Woche. Ein Glas Wein.
Ein Glas Wein.
Ja.
Herr Kehr, mitnehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine ganz ganz ganz Routinefrage.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Nein Herr Doktor, ich habe nie probiert.
Herr Kehr?
Aber Herr Doktor, vielleicht viele Schülerinnen nutzen solche Drogen oder zum Beispiel Mittelsurzeit?
Ja, es tut mir leid. Es tut mir leid, dass es so viel Suizid, Sie haben recht. Das ist ein großes Problem für uns, für alle.
Und wir sollen dagegen etwas machen.
Ja, ich bin Mathelehrer und beobachte das jeden Tag Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Kinder Herr Kehr?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Tochter.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie Angst haben. Wie viel ist Ihre Tochter?
Ja, Jura ist die Name meiner Tochter. Sie ist 25 Jahre alt und studiert auch. Entschuldigung, Jura. Sie studiert Jura.
Bei der Jura studiert sie.
Julia studiert Jura.
Ok, ich verstehe Sie, dass Sie Angst haben. Sie haben ganz ganz ganz recht.
Nein, nein. Jetzt bin ich sehr beunruhigt Herr Doktor.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch Herr Kehr?
Ja Herr Doktor, aber mein Vater, Entschuldigung, vor zwei Jahren ist mein Vater an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Beide sind verstorben Herr Doktor. Meine Mutter ist auch verstorben. Sie hatte vor drei Jahren einen Schlaganfall und...
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Daran ist sie verstorben. Sie hatte auch Bluthochdruck Herr Doktor. Ist der Bluthochdruck erblich?
Als theoretisch kann es sein, aber nicht ganz. Ja, das ist natürlich sehr wichtig.
Der Lebensstil, Ernährungsstil und Bewegung zum Beispiel Sport treiben ist sehr wichtig. Rauchen ist sehr wichtig.
Nicht nur verantwortlich, erblich.
Ok Herr Doktor. Alles klar.
Herr Kehr, was machen Sie beruflich?
Wie gesagt bin ich Mathelehrer.
Mathelehrer. Ich habe vergessen, Sie sind Mathelehrer. Sie sind verheiratet oder?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Sie haben eine Tochter Julia bei der Jura. 25 Jahre alt. Alles gut Herr Bayer.
Ich möchte nur die letzte Frage stellen. Wie lange dauert Ihre Atake? Brustschmerzen. Ich meine Brustschmerzen.
Wie gesagt, in den letzten drei Monaten hatte ich schon ab und zu ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ich habe nicht als Ataken beobachtet. Weiß ich nicht. Aber es war viel leichter als heute.
Ja, alles gut. Aber Herr Doktor, Sie möchten wissen, die Schmerzen kamen meistens bei Belastung.
Ja, natürlich.
Zum Beispiel beim Treppensteigen. Sie haben vielleicht 10 Minuten gefragt. Aber jetzt kann ich sagen, vielleicht 10 Minuten.
Vielen Dank für die Frage.
Es hat gedauert. Deshalb habe ich mir damals nicht so viele Gedanken gemacht, weil es nicht so stark war. Aber heute bin ich ...
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Treppen können Sie hochgehen, ohne Pause?
Damals, ich habe nie gerechnet. Aber ...
Vielleicht 2. Etage, 3. Etage?
Ja, ich wohne im 2. Etage.
Ohne Pause.
Ohne Pause konnte ich früher steigen. Aber seit den letzten drei Monaten muss ich eine Pause machen.
Wie viele Kilo tragen Sie?
Ich habe nicht gerechnet.
Ich habe nie gerechnet, Herr Doktor. Ich weiß nicht.
Alles gut. Herr Kehr, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Aber natürlich. Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe und ob ich hier bleiben soll oder muss.
Oder ob ich operiert werden soll.
Das kann ich momentan nicht genau sagen. Wir sollen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen, Herr Kehr. Aber sollen Sie aktuell hier bleiben?
Wenn alles gut läuft, können Sie gerne nach Hause gehen. Aber erst einmal sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Bitte seien Sie ein bisschen geduldig.
Wegen Angst habe ich viele Fragen im Kopf. Danke für Ihr Verständnis und für die Geduld, Herr Doktor. Danke.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Ich warte auf Sie, Herr Doktor.
Herr Kehr, Sie warten hier. In 30 Minuten können Sie wieder nach Hause gehen.
Dann können Sie weiter gehen. Alles gut.
Es gab keine typischen Fakas, aber es ist etwas, das mich nachher entspann.
Ich bin so beeindruckt.
Ich habe mich nicht so gut getrocknet wie erwartet.
Ich finde es sehr schön.
Herr Kettin, Sie waren sehr gut.
Herr Doktor, das ist normal. Er macht mich sogar in Lumbar-Zeiten sehr beeindruckt.
Er macht sehr schöne Reaktionen. Er ist ein guter Typ.
Aber es gibt extra Reaktionen, Herr Ekrem.
Herr Ekrem, du antwortest gut. Was ist das für ein Instinkt?
Wir hoffen, dass wir in der Natur sein werden. Wir werden es überlegen.
Vielen Dank.
Herzlichen Dank.
Herr Ekrem, möchte ich direkt beginnen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten bei der Notaufnahme aufgenommen und ihm die Ärzte vorstellen.
Sehr schön.
Es geht um Philipp Schaeher. Er ist 59 Jahre alt und wurde am 11.11.1965 geboren.
Er wiegt 19 Kilo und ist 1 Meter groß.
Heute Morgen kam er zu uns und stichelte und brann seit zwei Stunden auf.
Er hat die retrosyterne Brustschmerzen begonnen.
Er hat die Schmerzen vor zwei Stunden begonnen und am Anfang die Schmerzkarte brann und durcheinander.
Aber jetzt er bildet sich ausdrückend.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Das ist eine interessante Weise.
Die Schmerzen sind intensiv bei Belastung 6 von 10.
In Ruhe 3 bis 4 von 10 auf eine Schmerzkarte.
Entschuldigung, die Schmerzintensität liegt bei Belastung 6 von 10 oder in der Ruhe 4 von 10.
Oder am Anfang liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 6 von 10 und momentan 4 von 10.
Am Anfang liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 6 von 10.
Aber jetzt 4 von 10.
Die Schmerzen sind bei Belastung oder in der Ruhe aufgetreten.
Heute Morgen nach dem Frühstück.
Die Patientin sagt, dass er eine Schmerzen seit ein paar Monaten hatte.
Insbesondere beim Treppensteigen.
Die Attacke, wie lange dauert die Patientin weiß nicht.
Die Patienten sagen, dass sie seit zwei Stunden Schmerzen hatten.
Seit zwei Stunden begonnen.
Diese Attacke dauert seit zwei Stunden.
Aber vorher gibt es noch andere Atake oder Beschwerden.
Die Patienten sagen, dass es aber keine feste Zeit gibt.
Am Ende habe ich gehört, dass er ungefähr 10 Minuten gesagt hat.
Am Anfang haben Sie recht, dass er nichts daran erinnert hat.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Begleitend sind ein Gynaphektorist, Neuse, Dyspno, Kaltschweiß und Fetig.
Die Begegnung der Amnestischen ergab sich in Appetanz und Schlafsturm wegen Todangst.
Als Vorerkrankung leidet er seit 15 Jahren auf Arteriellhypertonie und Hyperkolesthymemie.
Er klagt über eine seit solange dauernde chronische Hüste ab und zu mit Sputum oder Auswurf.
Mit Kamantös nimmt er regelmäßig 5 mg Ramiplil täglich morgens und 40 mg Simvastatin täglich abends.
Er hat gegen Erdnuss eine Allergie und reagiert auf Mundschwellung und Atemnot.
Zu den Noxen der Patienten raucht seit 30 Jahren täglich 3 Zigaretten.
Bei dem Alkoholkonsum wurde er 1 Glas Wein pro Woche bejaht.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Bei der Familienanamnese berichtet er, der Vater ist an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Die Mutter ist an einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt mit der Familie zusammen.
Er hat eine Tochter, 25 Jahre alt, studiert Jura und ist gesund.
Er ist ein Mathelehrer.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf akute Koronarzentren.
Wer hat den Patienten für akute Koronarzentren?
Plötzlich aufgetretene Brustschmerzen.
Wer ist ein Zikofaktor?
Er ist seit 30 Jahren rauchen.
Wie viele Zigaretten hat er täglich?
Täglich 3 Zigaretten würde er bejaht.
3 Zigaretten?
Ja, 3 Zigaretten.
Das kommt mir auch interessant.
Aber jede Zigarettenmenge schädigt unseren Körper.
Sie haben recht.
Er leidet an arteriellen Hypertonin seit 5 Jahren.
Er leidet an Hyperkolesternemie.
Er trinkt Alkohol.
Er ist 90 Kilo.
Ein bisschen adipositas.
Aber wie groß ist er?
1,90 Meter groß.
1,90 Meter und er wiegt 90 Kilogramm.
Dann? Das bedeutet?
Ich rechne.
Ich glaube, dass er nicht adiposit ist.
Ja, ich denke, 22.
Er ist nicht adiposit.
Er ist normal.
Ich dachte nur Kilo.
Wenn ich 90 Kilo bin, dann kannst du sagen, du bist adiposit.
Aber ein Mann ist 1,90 Meter groß.
Wenn wir Risikofaktoren nennen, achten wir neben Feuerkrankungen und Alkoholkonsum auf die Familienanamnese.
Es gibt wichtige Informationen in der Familienanamnese.
Ich habe noch vergessen, Lebensstil, Fragen stellen, Sport treiben oder Arbeit belastung.
Diese Fragen habe ich leider vergessen.
In der Familienanamnese gibt es wichtige Informationen.
Der Vater ist verstorben durch Herzinfarkt.
Das ist eine genetische Belastung.
Die Mutter leidet an Schlaganfall.
Schlaganfall auf eine Gefäßeprobleme.
Ja, Mathe, Skoda.
Okay.
Man kann beide sagen. Schlaganfall und Herzinfarkt.
Welche Differentialdiagnostik kommen in Betracht?
Als Differentialdiagnostik kommen eine Gastroesophagealreflukrankheit und eine Artkoaktation.
Was bedeutet Artkoaktation?
Eine Artkoaktation.
Differentialdiagnostik.
Das ist eine Artkoaktation.
Sie können die Artkoaktation Lungenembolie als Differentialdiagnost nennen.
Sie haben schon während des Gesprächs eine Frage gestellt und die Pulmonarembolie ausgeschlossen.
Ist Ihnen abgefahren, dass Sie die Gespräche gelesen haben?
Ja, meine Differentialdiagnostik ist eine Gastroesophagealreflukrankheit und Lungenembolie.
Okay.
Das ist eine Differentialdiagnostik.
So weiter in Abklärung. Was würden Sie durchführen?
Als erstes würde ich eine Köpfe in die Hose geben.
Blutbild, Badeblutbild, Nehrung und Leberwerte und Herzensien,
Töponin und Kratinkneas MB und Genomparametal.
Haben Sie schon Blut abgenommen?
Ja, schon.
Ich habe eine EKG verschrieben.
Ich habe eine Eschokardiographie und einen Kardiologischen Konsil anfordert.
Was noch?
Bei dieser Erklärung können Sie sagen, ich habe schon eine Unterbrechung gemacht
und während des Gesprächs habe ich schon Blut abgenommen,
eine EKG geschrieben und die Vitalparameter überprüft.
Hier sagen Sie diese Information.
Ich empfehle Ihnen.
Sollen wir das simulieren? Vielleicht Töponin ein bisschen hoch?
Nein, nein. Du solltest keine Ergebnisse geben.
Du solltest nur nennen, was Sie gemacht haben.
Ja, ich verstehe. Alles gut.
Bei der Anamnesigesprache habe ich die Unterbrechung untergebracht
und habe sofort eine EKG durchgeführt und Blut abgenommen.
Bei der Anamnesigesprache habe ich die Nerven, die Leber,
ein Differentialblutbild und Herz-Enzyme-Kardiokapher.
Warum ein Differentialblutbild?
Das ist eine Routine.
Nein, ein Blutbild ist ein Blutbild.
Ja, ein Blutbild.
Töponin und T und Kratenkenas, MB und Genoparameter,
auch sehr wichtig.
Gernungsparameter.
Gernungsparameter. Muss ich das erklären?
P, T, P, T, T und ...
Nein, nicht P, T, T.
B, T, T.
Weil Pimanoiremboli ist ein Diasporasial Diagnose.
Weil die Pimanoiremboli Diagnose ausschließlich sind.
Dann wurde eine EKG durchgeführt und ein Kardiolikschekkonzil angefordert.
Nach dem Ergebnis ...
Wie soll ich das erklären?
Weil die Patientin sich gut fühlt,
habe ich gesagt, dass wir weiter mit ihr reden.
Das muss man nicht sagen.
Jetzt kannst du normalerweise die EKG-Kartier-Karten sagen.
Verstanden.
Schau mal, Ahmet ...
Aparativ ...
EKG-B.
Was haben wir in der Zeit?
Nein, Aparativ bedeutet ...
Aparativ bedeutet, dass du Blut hast,
die Körperwerte unterzuhunken,
die Viterbryämie kontrollieren,
die EKG machen.
Die restlichen Tätigkeiten sind Aparativ.
Das ist wie das Eko.
Ein anderer Patient ist wie das CT-Tätigen.
Ein anderer Patient ist wie ein anderes Ultrasurial.
Das sind Aparativ-Mitglieder.
Aparativ-Werde-Ekokardiographie.
Kannst du hier Aparativ-Tätigkeiten machen?
Ich denke, das Eko ist nicht möglich.
Du kannst hier alles machen, aber du musst es sagen.
Aparativ bedeutet nicht, dass du es nimmst.
Aparativ bedeutet, dass du es nimmst.
Was hast du noch?
Nein, nein.
Ich denke, dass das Aparativ-Mitglieder Eko ist.
Aparativ-Diagnostik ist eine Eko-Kardiographie.
Das ist ein Röntgen-Torax.
Gegemanflas ist CT-Angioterapie.
Bei Bedarf ein coronare Angioterapie würde ich empfehlen.
Für diesen Fall.
Wie würden Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Wenn mein Verdachtdiagnos bestätigt ist,
möchte ich diese Patientstation aufnehmen.
Welche Station?
Intensivstation.
Auf jeden Fall zum Intensivstation aufnehmen.
Mit Montageüberwachung.
Ich werde nach der Morphine-Sauerstoffgabe
auf jeden Fall Nitroglycerin,
ASS, Heparin und Clopdorfer Monabeschem.
Und Betablocker.
Wenn der Patient eine Stand bekommt,
dann geben wir eine Clopidograhe.
Zweite Thrombocytin-Aggregation.
Aber am Anfang geben wir nicht Clopidograhe.
Monabeschemma, Morphine, Oxidation.
Clopdorfer Monabeschemma.
Clopdorfer, Statin, Betablocker, ASS, Heparin,
Angiotensin-Resteptor und Antagonist.
Ich bin ein Psychotherapist. Ich bin als Sekundäretherapie vertreten.
Aber Mono-BH, das ist nicht so.
Morphin, Oxygen, Nitroblasen, A, S, S und Heparin.
Und Mono-BH, das ist Betablocker.
Mono-BH, das ist Betablocker.
Ich habe das M, Mono, B kodiert.
Mono-Türn, Mono, Morphin, Oxygen, Nitroblasen, Aspirin und Betablocker.
Das sieht aus wie Mono-BHM, aber Betablocker, das ist Sekundärtherapie.
Statin, Betablocker, Raketogral, A, S, H, M oder A, R Blocker.
Sekundärtherapie, die anderen Situationen der Patient betrachtet.
Danke, Ekrem. Ich habe ein paar Dinge zu sagen.
Als ich die Unterbrechung gemacht habe, habe ich gesagt, dass ich die Beratung beenden werde.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich die stationäre Aufnahme machen werde.
Ich glaube, ich sage das nicht so.
Nicht enden, nicht stationäre Aufnahmen.
Ja, ich möchte jetzt das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich werde das gleiche mit der EKG-Schreibung, etwas Blutabnehmen, um ihre Herzfunktionen zu beurteilen.
Das ist genug zu sagen.
Ich werde die EKG-Schreibung beurteilen, um die Herzfunktionen zu beurteilen.
Dann werde ich die Köln- und Weiterefüße beurteilen.
Wie fühlst du dich jetzt? Bist du besser?
Du bist nicht in die Situation, die Zeit ist sehr lang.
Du musst es in 18-19 Minuten machen.
Ich möchte das Gespräch kurz beenden.
Ich werde die EKG-Schreibung beurteilen, um die Herzfunktionen zu beurteilen.
Dann werde ich die Köln- und Weiterefüße beurteilen.
Das ist schon zu beachten.
Das ist besser, um Zeit zu verlieren.
Wenn du das Ende beenden willst, ist das Gespräch zu Ende.
Dann gehen wir auf einen anderen Ort.
Aber du küsst das Gespräch, dann wirst du weiter.
Ich gehe nur in diese Art.
Du machst das im Schockraum.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Du machst die Untabrasion und die Bartolom-Tadrock und dann den Aufnahmegeistpray.
Ja, so können wir das Arbeiten machen.
Wir werden es morgen auch in der ACS machen.
Dann werden wir es sehen.
Dann, wenn du Fragen hast, das sage ich dir nicht, sondern allen.
Manche Fragen müssen wir uns als Beispiel darstellen.
Ich habe es gefragt, aber es hat nicht geantwortet.
Ich hatte den Schuss auf den Schuss.
Es war ein Problem, dass wir nicht zusammen waren.
Du hast es auch gesagt, als du mit dem Schuss gesprochen hast.
Ich habe es gedacht, aber ich habe es nicht gehört.
Ich habe die Schuss gefragt, weil Florian in der Anamnesie eine Schuss hat.
Es war ein Problem.
Es war ein Problem, dass wir nicht zusammen waren.
Ich habe es zuerst gesagt, dass es sehr intensiv war.
Ich habe es gesagt, weil Ekrem schreit, dass er nicht den Schuss hört.
Dann habe ich gesagt, dass es sehr oft ein Problem ist.
Du sprichst, der Schuss spricht, du sprichst auch.
Es war ein Problem.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Schuss zu spät.
Oder ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe es gehört.
Du hast dich z.B. am Brust verletzt.
Du hast auch den Pneumatorenkontakt ausgedrückt.
Das ist auch ein Problem.
Was kannst du sagen?
Du hast dich z.B. aufgetreten.
Du hast dich gestreit.
Du hast eine Stresssituation erlebt.
Was muss man fragen, um die ganzen Fragen zu stellen?
Lufnot, Engegefühl, das sind alle Fragen.
Ich habe Lufnot, Engegefühl und das sind alle Fragen.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen mit Brust Schmerzen gefragt.
Wo, Zeit, wann, Strahlen.
Dann habe ich diese Frage gestellt.
Lufnot, Engegefühl, das sind alle Fragen.
Wenn du die Frage hast, die du nicht selbst gefragt hast,
dann sagst du, dass du es nicht gut ist.
Lufnot, Engegefühl, das sind alle Fragen.
Wo, Strahlen, Engegefühl, das sind alle Fragen.
Dann habe ich 10 Fragen mitgebracht.
Ich habe ihnen diese beiden Fragen gezeigt.
Die haben alle Fragen.
Ich möchte euch sagen, dass wir nicht immer die Anamneskontrolle
mit der Analyse verabschieden.
Wir benutzen keine Fahbegriff.
Wenn ihr Vertigo oder Schwindel habt,
dann fragt ihr immer, was das ist.
Ihr denkt, dass ihr es nicht genau verabschieden könnt.
Wenn ihr mit einem normalen Doktor-Kommission
mit einem Patienten-Kommission zu sprechen,
dann ist es schwer.
Ihr sagt es meistens zusammen.
Ihr sagt es nicht zusammen.
Ihr sagt es nur für den Patienten.
Ich werde die Fragen in die Kommentare stellen.
Ich möchte sie nicht beunruhigen.
Sie haben typische Beschwerden für Herzkrankheit.
Deswegen möchte ich das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich werde eine EKG schreiben und etwas Blut abnehmen,
um ihre Herzfunktion zu verabschieden.
Ich möchte sie nicht beunruhigen.
Sie haben typische Beschwerden für Herzkrankheit.
Zwar beовать ihr euch den Schmerzverkauf,
aber für den Schmerz der Ärger.
Sobald ein Patient eine Schmerzkrankheit hat,
kann er den Schmerzverkauf nicht elauen.
In der Zeit hat man seine Äffnung ausgeführt.
Sobald ein Patient eine Schmerzkrankheit hat,
kann er den Schmerzverkauf nicht elauen.
Dann Apathit, Gewicht, Schlaf.
Hier habe ich viele Symptome für die Krankheit.
Schlaf ist ein Problem.
Hier ist Todesankt.
Dann ist es das Übelkait.
Jetzt frage ich das Gasoentestensystem.
Übelkait, Erwachen, Stuhlgang oder Vaselasenprobleme.
Übelkait habe ich hierher.
Und das Gethetypannamnese ist auch fertig.
Dann kommt das klassische.
Wir machen weiter.
Die wichtigste Reaktion ist, das Gas zu kassieren.
Das haben wir schon gesprochen.
Die anderen Reaktionen sind Todesankt.
Das wird man auch oft sagen.
Man kann vielleicht sagen,
dass man Angst hat, dass man sich verständigt.
Aber man ist jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Und man ist in guten Hand und hat unsere Bestesphysie.
Das soll man den Patienten entspannen.
Ja, man kann sich verreisen.
Aber wir sind jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Und wir werden das Beste für euch machen.
Ihr könnt euch entspannen.
Dann ist die Mutter, der Vater,
herrschen und verurteilt.
Daher ist man auch Angst.
Ich bin auch Angst.
Aber wir werden sofort an den Anfang der Handung.
Ich verstehe, was ihr Angst habt.
Wenn ihr auch Angst habt,
dann könnt ihr es auch haben.
Wir haben es schon gemacht.
Ihr müsst nicht Angst haben.
Ich verstehe, was ihr Angst habt.
Ihr könnt auch Herzinfarkt haben.
Aber wir werden sofort an den Anfang der Handung.
Wir werden direkt zur Therapie beginnen.
Das ist das, was ich sagen will.
Das sind die wichtigsten Dinge.
Florian ist ein Beispiel.
Hier ist eine Frau, die über die Date geht.
Das ist nicht so.
Er hat eine 11-jährige Frau.
In der Pubertage.
Er erzählt seine Probleme.
Seine Frau hat ihn verreist.
Dann sagt er,
dass seine Schwester eine Krampf-Adamsin ist.
Er fragt, ob er eine Krampf-Adamsin ist.
Sein Vater hat einen Grüne Starn.
Er fragt viele Dinge.
Er fragt, ob das Erdlich ist.
Erdlich ist, was wir immer sagen.
Ich verstehe, was ihr Angst habt.
Ich bin auch Angst.
Ich verstehe ihre Angst.
Das ist nicht unbedingt.
Es gibt viele Falschen, die ursachen.
Zum Beispiel.
Er fragt, ob das Erdlich ist.
Und dann sagt er,
dass seine Schwester eine Krampf-Adamsin ist.
Wie wird sie behandelt?
Und so weiter.
Und dann sagt er,
dass seine Schwester nicht unterzucht ist.
Ich empfehle ihr,
dass sie eine Krampf-Adamsin ist.
Und dass sie eine gute Behandlung bekommen.
Das kann man so sagen.
Wenn ihr etwas für die Tätigkeit sagt,
dann könnt ihr es auch dort beantworten.
Es gibt viele Falschen, die eine Therapie möglich sind,
um eine Kompression zu machen.
Und so weiter.
Aber hier ist etwas wichtig.
Dass man die Erklärung der Patientin
kurz beantworten kann.
Es ist wichtig, etwas kurz zu sagen.
Wir sprechen das später.
Wir haben jetzt noch andere Dinge.
Sie mögen das nicht.
Es ist wichtig, etwas kurz zu sagen.
Es geht um ihre Schwester.
Sie spricht über die Probleme in der Puberthate-Zeit.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Puberthate ist eine
und wir sind schon ein paar Jahre
in unserem Leben.
Das ist etwas wie das.
Puberthate-Zeit ist eine
und wir sind schon ein paar Jahre in unserem Leben.
아 nd ihr session
im Leben.
Ich onde jetzt hier die S מ h an
die ich gehört habe
Ich lege dies in booster
ahh
roz
sugars
h
Rider
Sie können einfach eine bequeme Schüre vermeiden.
Sie können zum Hausarzt oder Hautarzt besuchen.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Er ist Philip Kea. Er ist 59 Jahre alt.
Er wurde am 11. November 1965 geboren.
Er ist 1 Meter groß und 90 Kilogramm schwer.
Er kam heute zu uns.
Seit 2 Stunden plötzlich aufgetretene Postprandial-Toraxschmerzen.
Die Schmerzkarakteren seien dümpfend und drückender.
Am Anfang starrte die Schmerzen in einem Intensitäts-Standard von 6 von 10.
Aber jetzt liegen 3 bis 4 von 10.
Er schöpft und hat Todesangst.
Er erwähnt eine vegetative Anamnese.
Er hat Schmerzbedingte in Appetens und Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen.
Er hat seit 5 Jahren Blut-Arterie-Hypertonie.
Er hat 5 Milligramm Ramiplill.
Er leidet seit 10 Jahren an Hyperlipidemia.
Er nimmt 40 Milligramm abends ein.
Er berichtet auch Kranichschwüsten seit mindestens 20 Jahren.
Die Anfalloperation ist unrelevant.
Als Allergien bekannt ist Erdnussallergie.
Es ausdrückt Atemnot und Schwellung im Mund.
Er hat seit 30 Jahren Drei Zigaretten und Alkoholkonsum.
Er hat ein Glas Alkoholkonsum.
Er leidet vor zwei Jahren verstorben.
Er hat einen Herzanfall.
Er leidet vielleicht.
Er ist vor drei Jahren an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Wie Herr Kea, er leidet an Arterie-Hypertonie.
Er leidet vor drei Jahren an Arterie-Hypertonie.
Aufgrund ihrer Familiengeschichte empfehle ich,
aufgrund ihrer Familiengeschichte empfehle ich,
Niko-Tin oder Alkohol-Karenz und Alkohol-Karenz.
Ich habe eine kleine Behandlung von Therapie.
Ich würde gerne eine kardiologische Konsüle durchführen.
Wie fühlst du dich, Ketin?
Du fühlst dich nicht, als ob du dich nicht bewegen würdest?
Ich bin sehr verspannt, wenn ich mich an die Situation befinde.
und die Motivation zu sagen, dass es gut ist.
Deswegen könnt ihr einige Fakten normal spielen.
Danke, du hast recht.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es richtig.
Es entsteht ein Archiv.
Es entsteht ein spezifisches Archiv für Düsseldorf-Fakten.
Ich finde das Archiv eigentlich sehr wert.
Es ist sehr nötig für die nächsten Leute,
ich habe viel gelernt.
Deswegen habe ich mir die Reaktionen,
die ich vorhin gemacht habe,
um die ganzen Fakten zu beherrschen.
Ja, das machst du sehr gut.
Aber jetzt werden wir sehen,
dass wir noch zu Beginn sind.
Die Fakten bis jetzt waren die schwersten.
Die nächsten Fakten werden wir sehen.
Einige haben nicht so viele Reaktionen.
Es gibt nur 2-3 Reaktionen.
Genau, die vorigen waren schwierig.
Die vorigen waren schwierig.
Ja, die vorigen waren schwierig.
Wenn du dich selbst hast,
hat ein Freund sehr aggressiv gemacht.
Das ist wirklich alles.
Er ist wirklich aggressiv.
Das hat mein Trainer, mein Trainer Ibrahim,
auch beteiligt.
Dann hat er gesagt,
dass er immer einen Florian brauchen muss.
Er hat gesagt, dass er sich verbessern muss.
Er verbessert sich, aber hier ist der Balance sehr wichtig.
Wir leben immer Trauma,
weil wir in der Leben entwickeln.
Wir sind Menschen.
Wir müssen immer sehen, was wir machen können.
Das ist besonders wichtig für Frauen.
Männer können in diesem Sinne etwas mehr fest sein.
Aber ich denke, sie brauchen es auch.
Deshalb, Professor Chesin,
wie ich gesagt habe,
ihr müsst immer einfach spielen.
Meher, du hast 23 Fakten gesagt.
Wir machen 21, oder?
Wir machen 23 Fakten.
Wir haben Divert-Kulitiz,
Akut-Koronar-Syndrom,
und so weiter.
Deswegen sind es jetzt 23 Fakten.
Okay, okay.
Okay, hier, Professor Ibrahim.
Ich sage es einfach so, Professor Meher.
Ich habe nicht viel zu sagen,
aber ich habe eine Suche.
Außerdem, als ich die Artistik-Sektion
in der Art gesehen habe,
ist die Artistik-Sektion
die zwischen den Fakten,
die am meisten aus der Differenz-Diagnose aussehen,
die am meisten aus der heutigen Praxis aussehen,
die Akkurentempoly, Lungen-Arterienempoly
und das Gas-Ösefektor-Reflex-Krankheit.
Es wäre besser, die beiden zu belegen.
Für die Einheit.
Natürlich gibt es die Artistik-Sektion,
natürlich auch die Pneumothorax,
natürlich auch die Pneumonik,
die das Herz-Rasen, die Leuchttür-Kaltzüge.
Aber für den Test,
meine Meinung ist,
in der Differenz-Diagnose
Lungen-Arterienempoly
und das Gas-Ösefektor-Reflex-Krankheit
zu belegen.
Denn in den Fragen
wurde nicht eine bestimmte Frage
in der Artistik-Sektion gestellt.
Aber wenn Sie zum Beispiel
die Arten-Sektion,
wäre der cancer출ள das Graf des Armes veredingt.
Besonders,
als der Blutverdienung zum Anxilisieren
verwendet.
Oder die Annex new bonnancion....
was sagten Sie?
Ich finde es einfacher, wenn ich es in der Sprache verhebe.
Ich sage es in der Türkisch und der Alpern.
Es wird in zwei Wörtern verwendet.
Ich möchte noch etwas sagen.
Das Thema der Betablocker.
In diesem Schema wird die Betablocker in den Schemensprachen
den Yenach Heart Frequenzen bezeichnet.
Wir geben die Betablocker für alle Patienten.
Das ist die Höhe des Gehirns.
Wir nehmen eine Yenach Heart Frequenz an.
Denn Betablocker können die Patienten direkt aus dem Yenach Heart frequenzen.
Einige Yenach Heart Frequenzen kommen mit Bradycardi.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Insbesondere die inferior Yenach Heart Frequenzen.
Wenn du den Patienten mit Betablocker vergeben,
dann verbringst du ihn direkt aus dem Yenach Heart Frequenz.
Das ist nicht verabschieden.
Da muss ein Wort dazugeben.
Also kann man die Betablocker für alle Patienten nicht vergeben.
Also, wie wir die Hypotensik-Pastaklyser nicht vergeben,
werden wir die Betablocker für alle Patienten nicht vergeben.
In diesem Fall werden uns theoretisch die Fragen an einen generellen Doktor stellen.
Wie soll es dich vergeben?
Hast du das unter anderem gemacht?
Was ist die Unterschiede zwischen den Tropholin-Ebenen?
Welche Statspecifik?
Welche Medikamenten?
Und Cardiologik?
Das haben wir alle gesagt.
Ja, 3-5 mg.
Und eine andere Dauer ist Nitroglycerin.
Ist Nitroglycerin für alle Patienten verwendet?
Nein, das ist nicht verwendet.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Es steht in den Noten, aber es ist,
dass wir das für alle Patienten in der Intravene oder in der Dauer vergeben.
Es gibt eine Tabletform, die Sublingeispray.
Nitroglycerin-Spray.
Das ist die gleiche Spray-Apparat wie die Nitrospray.
Die ganze Puff ist 0,4 mg.
Wenn der Patient auf Tension ist, kann er 2 Puffs aus 1-mal auspuffen.
Also 0,8 mg.
Sublingual-Form.
Du legst den Lauf, drücke den Spray,
der Patient wartet, nicht lüftet.
Er zeigt sich unter dem Lauf.
Was wichtig ist, in Nitroglycerin,
wer wir nicht vergeben.
1.
In Anamnesin, wie Sildenafil, Viagra, Tadenafil,
wenn es für den Patienten mit Medikamenten gibt,
kontinuiert.
Wenn du den Patienten mit Nitroglycerin
in der letzten Krise mit Sildenafil, Viagra, Tadenafil,
Sildenafil, Sialis,
das ist sehr wichtig.
Das ist nicht vergeben.
Und das ist nicht vergeben.
Was ist mit Aspirin?
In Deutschland gibt es Intravenous Formen.
In der Türkei geben wir Aspirin oral.
Hier nicht falsch oral.
Es ist im Test sehr verletzend.
Intravenous Acetylsalazoide.
Das werden wir sagen.
Das Dosen ist 250-500 ml.
Intravenous.
Betabologer,
je n'a-hers fracans, das habe ich gesagt.
Heparin geben wir auch.
Intravenous ist 70 Kilogramm.
Das ist nicht für alle 5000.
Das ist nicht vergeben.
Ok.
Das ist auch nicht vergeben.
Das ist aber nicht vergeben.
Und das ist nicht vergeben.
Das ist nicht vergeben.
Nicht vergeben.
Und das ist nicht vergeben.
Hodja,
Du hast die Nitrobehandlung
0.4.
Und 2.
Ich wollte es nicht verhindern, aber ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, dass wir die Tension der Nitovirus-Serie für die guten Patienten geben.
Hier wird nicht Hypotensiv sein.
In unseren Klauseln steht 90-60, aber in Simulationen 100 mm.
Die Grenzen der Hypotension sind kardiologisch 90, diastolig 60 mm.
Sie müssen es jemandem an dieser Grenze geben.
Ich gebe in der Klinik praktisch nicht bis zu 110-120 Nitro.
Ich habe es gesagt, weil es Hypotension in der Schacht gibt.
Es kann etwas schwer sein.
Aber praktisch ist es nicht Hypotensiv.
90-60, in Simulationen 100 mm.
In welcher Situation ist Nitovirus?
Wenn es mit Hypertensiv-Atak passiert,
wenn die Tension über 180 ist,
dann ist es mit Emaillen.
Emaillen können auch in Hypertensiv-Mitglied kommen.
Es ist nicht nur Hypotensiv.
Man kann es in 10 Minuten oder so.
Es gibt nur 2-mal Emaillen.
Wenn es mit Emaillen geht,
oder wenn es mit Emaillen geht,
dann kann es mit Emaillen gehen.
Kannst du mir das erzählen?
Ich habe dich gefragt, ich werde es nicht erzählen.
Ich möchte dich nicht mit dem anderen beantworten.
Ich glaube, es ist sehr schön.
Danke, Sümeyra.
Du hast alles verabschiedet.
Nur ein paar E-Klips.
Sind die Szenarien nur in die Einrichtung der Systeme?
Ja, sie können.
Akut-Corner-Syndrom ist eine Übersicht.
Was sagen sie?
Ober-Griffe?
Übersicht.
Akut-Corner-Syndrom ist gleich.
Im Herzblut ist eine Übersicht in der Koronareterrie.
Wenn du es dir sagt,
ist es die Übersicht der Koronareterrie.
Du kannst es dir nicht sagen,
dass es eine Übersicht ist.
Wenn du es dir sagt,
ist es die Übersicht der Koronareterrie.
Es kann in 3 Formen sein.
Akut-Corner-Syndrom ist eine Übersicht.
Einst un stabil anginen.
Un stabil.
Este hebung myokard infakt.
Non este hebung myokard infakt.
Es gibt 3 Formen.
Das kann ich kurz erzählen.
Kann man es fragen?
Es dauert 30 Minuten.
Ich glaube, es wird viel zu fragen.
Aber du musst es mir nicht erzählen.
Du hast es in den Erfahrungen.
Akut-Corner-Syndrom ist unfast.
Nicht-System.
Unstabil Angine Pectoris.
Du kannst es kurz erzählen.
Was ist ein System?
Transmurale.
Myokard infakt.
Wir erwarten bei Systeme.
EKG-Veränderungen.
Erfurtetroponin.
Und CKM1.
Ein Beispiel.
Ich erwarte bei Systeme.
EKG-Veränderungen.
Erfurtetroponin.
Und CKM1.
Erwarte bei Systeme.
EKG-Veränderungen.
Es kann sein.
Es kann nicht sein.
Aber es kann auch erfurtetroponin.
Und CKM1 sein.
Aber Unstabil Angine Pectoris.
Erwarten wir keine EKG-Veränderungen.
Das ist ein System.
EKG-Veränderungen.
Und Blutveränderungen.
Blutveränderungen.
Das ist es.
Aber es ist ein Problem.
Ich habe es schon mal in der Frage gestellt.
Ja, es gibt.
Es ist nicht nur für die Testung.
Es ist auch für die Medikamente.
Hallo Freunde.
Hallo.
Die neue Gruppe wird mit 12 anfangen.
Okay.
Ich möchte nicht lange sagen.
Jeder Medikament muss das akut korneum.
Wer das ist,
muss das praktisch wissen.
Das ist die generelle Regelung der Welt.
Es ist nicht nur für die Testung.
EKG-Veränderungen müssen wissen.
Und Troponin.
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ich möchte das nicht sagen.
Aber ein paar Sätze sollte man sagen.
Wenn es nicht um Kardiologie geht,
dann ist es nicht so.
Nur die Namen sind genug.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so.
Aber die Noten sind auch da.
Es ist ein ganzes Thema.
Es ist wie eine Frage von Kardiologie.
Ich weiß nicht.
Es kann auch werden.
Ist es noch eine Frage?
Okay, wir haben keine Fragen mehr.
Die Gruppe beginnt.
Bis morgen.
Ich habe Akut Korneum.
Tschüss.